Rather than telling you which chart I would choose and why,
since we have the power of a web-based visualization library at our disposal,
dimple.js, you do not have to take my word for it.
We can experiment with each of the chart types.
A common theme that we will be bring up over and
over again throughout the course is the process of iterating on a visualization.
This is often called prototyping or sketching.
I wanted to show you the process I went through to come to
my own conclusions about the chart type and
hopefully make designing visualizations seem much less mysterious.
And since there is never truly a right answer with visualizations,
just like there's no right way to write a book or
a news article, once empowered with the insights I will now go through,
you can hopefully extend and adapt my visualization to make it your own.
We will see later in this lesson why some of the design decisions that
the creator of D3 made makes this process of iterating and
experimenting with visual displays quite seamless.
And sometimes, even if there is a right or best chart to visualize your data,
you often don't know ahead of time how the data will interact with the aesthetic
of your visualization, including things like layout, color, scales, and
how will it interact with the web page itself.
We have already seen which aspects of the grammar of graphics the creator of D3
chose to implement in his design decisions for the library, and how this makes
the process of iterating and experimenting with visual displays quite seamless.